hi again life hacks 104 this time Johnny
is not here 1 104 is in somewhere hot
sweating in this complaining that work
being 105 kilos is too large see we're
in for coming here 105 kilos it was his
choice to move all the 120s wasn't it as
a powerlifting so yeah that is oh I
really forgot Oh nearly left nearly left
the phone on airplane mode oh my god oh
there we go you know that one time the
one time the font inherit Oh most fun
ring me started yeah so like facts 104
who's gonna go first here we go first
sure right so one that I've realized
that I've been using seamlessly as you
said it's the ones that the most
background that are probably the most
useful for you yeah but they're the
least ones they're not the ones you peel
oh yeah do not think integrate
themselves so seamlessly in your life
it's like talking about breathing or
talking about eating exactly so what is
water to a fish yeah so split wise
okay it's one that so this is a tool
that's free there is a paid version for
these so the paid version is so high
powered that you just don't move either
so it's too much optimization yeah
exactly so if you live in a flat share
and one of you handles the bills this is
phenomenal so it's got like a there's
like a machine learning element to it
and everything but what it is each
person gets an account you join a group
which is your flat and then you input
expenses so you can set recurring
expenses that are like a little horse
farm council tax here and you can input
individual ones it then creates a
running tally of how much each person is
owed and so enabled it will offset based
on what other people have bought so if
you paid the council tax and then your
flatmate goes and buy some toilet roll
yeah and puts it into split buyers and
people
balance it again this is just like your
wet dream incredible and then once a
month it sends you all an email saying
who is owed what well and as you type in
electricity or whatever you know British
Gas or whatever it will then detect
it'll based on the words that are typed
in it'll create a little icon like
lightbulb categorize under electricity
and utilities wah
yeah that's a stiffy inducing for you
it's incredible that's all that sounds
really really good I remember when I was
at uni like we left with I'm pretty
certain still like three or four cc J's
out for like her some of the people at
my flat because they'd left without like
pay in there a bit yeah isn't he's an
absolute [ __ ] I wish there was a
better app for working out who was what
at the end of a meal because we go out
for food all the time and it's an
absolute nightmare and I'm sat there
with one couple pasted up as you go
along if so I just I have I come over
and the start is here and then it's you
know like an iPad menu where you just
say what about that man it just charges
you yeah rather Gartner right my one
home I'm gonna start with right okay so
what's up web not everyone knows that
there is a desktop browser based partner
to what's up you did removing it I know
okay you just opening is it Alfred yeah
so basically if you go to
web.whatsapp.com and then scan the QR
code with your phone when your phones on
what's up you get all of the functions
of what's up you only have to scan the
code once and then it stays logged in
and yeah you you get all of your chats
all you broadcast lists all your groups
you can upload files and photos directly
from your desktop its web its
browser-based so if you go to if you're
away from your normal computer and you
want to use it then you can just log in
is such a game changer when we're
talking about strategies to try and
reduce our phone usage and get away from
the human in the loop
idiosyncratic use of your phone this is
one of the best ways because you use
your laptop for distinctly different
purposes and use your phone for it's
very easy to go on - what's up - do
with something which you can quote
unquote have as productive and then
tumble into Instagram Facebook Twitter
so on and so forth whereas on your
laptop personally for me I find that my
time is a lot more it's a lot more
directed it's definitely a lot more
mindful so yeah it means phone can be
down face down and obviously if you've
got a MacBook as we said life hacks one
on one the first one that we said was
Apple product if you've got iMessage
linked up between your MacBook and your
iPhone you've got your two main
platforms if it's a giant phone on get
your phone on your laptop yeah exactly
which is unbelievable so I'm part of
team fat thumbs as well and I just can't
like I'm using it I use an iPhone se
which is the same sizes of five yeah and
texting is just a nightmare every time I
like I really up [ __ ] you're texting on
my phone but only do it when I have to
so what's that web at least it means
that you can write out a more considered
response because you're not dealing with
the arse on the trying to text something
like I'm just gonna send and I've got
myself in trouble by sending short
messages or trying to be too concise
because I can't be bothered to type it
on I know this is like something with
like our first of all problem like yeah
I know but I'd rather batch process
what's up type it properly on computer
ya know after the evolved our screen on
the side of that control command in
space on a MacBook that brings up the
emoji menu now this is going to trigger
Yousef because he has an even more
shortcut way of getting them up but for
mere mortals like myself and most of you
who are less are god this is when I
realize how lame I am so it's a great
shortcut the only reason I've set I put
Alfred quicker version is because it
takes about 1 to 1.5 seconds to load and
it does take a little bit so that's just
too long for you but yet can if you have
your MacBook up and you press
control/command and I'm going to make
sure this is actually correct or else
I'm going to be giving people yeah
control Commandments space it's quicker
on yours actually maybe I'm just gonna
slow mark and yeah it brings up the full
emoji keyboard so if you're writing
statuses or what's up web iMessage stuff
like that again it's it's in deck
say as he start typing watermelon ooh
yeah it'll come up here it's it I used
to have all of my commonly used ones in
a note on notes and then go on to know
how to copy them out and then I found
control/command in space and I don't
even need to be there write them on what
do you want to do next what's your next
so my next one is I'll by the way just
before we go onto this
speaking of split wise you haven't
paying your friends Apple pay cash is
coming out soon which is gonna be a way
that you can just I message your friends
money okay
so again with the paying the bill and
stuff it'll probably be all integrated
into something like that and you just
send the text exactly sends the money
across so we could maybe even with meals
and things it could even be to the kalam
personal house that pays the bill and
everyone just texts in the morning yes
give some cash yeah so maybe not moving
on we talked about Alfred and the emoji
search so you can either do ctrl command
space or if you use Alfred and you
listen to it one of the other life hacks
why we mention it every time because
it's incredible is a shortcut that see
so for me if I'm just typing an emoji
Speight it open or it's a command space
e and then just type the word so e lemon
that will come up with the emoji now
another discovery I made on a fritter
yesterday it's the Google search so you
can now do a built in Google search
function so let's say I want to type I
want to find my Ramadan article on
protein fitness okay
it gives you an inline response okay we
see and yeah
so that's lovely yeah that is cool so
then if I want to copy the link I just
do that and then paste the link to
people so basically just everyone should
download Alfred I don't think we've
actually gotten top to bottom on what
Alfred is can you very very very
basically explain what it here so all
those so if you've used a Mac and you've
opened spotlight which is the universal
search bar that comes up with it's a
currency converter a calculator file
search any of those things
Alfred is like that but it's a bit more
super-powered it's like it's like that
on star
it's like at speed at the same time yeah
exactly and so it's faster on steroids
and this workflows as well so you can it
builds in certain keys or shortcuts or
whatever that'll do a bunch of things so
you can like select a file and then
Alfred will move it to the folder that
you want it to or you can open a website
in about two key presses or whatever so
and it's written up it's a very very
powerful shortcut just great like you
can call people with it open bookmarks I
found to the other day there's a plugin
that you can get for it where it'll
tweet from Alfred so I can just be on
here now and in fact I'm going to do
this right that's the same as spotlight
so so I can command in space I can type
in the word tweet which goes sent tweet
and then all I need to do is type I am
tweeting from alfred press return is
raised and it'll send it'll send a tweet
up and then it will give me a little bit
but you're gonna say we're recording
lifehacks 104 tune in but no yeah I'm
tweeting from a minute it's definitely
accurate it's what happened exactly so
so the reason that this Google search
thing is so useful at least for me I'm
sure that you guys listening like if you
ever have to constantly bring up links
or whatever for work and paste someone a
link now that you can just type it in
there you know that it's gonna be the
first thing on Google because you know
the specific keywords and you just paste
it to the main singer so this is this is
another one of the things to do with
life hacks you are so far you're so deep
in the Alfred you are up to the hips in
it I have an hour-long webinar on Alfred
Deakin the problem is you've missed off
some of the best stuff because it's too
basic so the the most used things for me
on Alfred are the fact that it gives you
a clipboard history so if you if you can
imagine that when you copy something on
a normal MacBook you you only can
command + V you can only pace you
overwrite that the most recent you think
are that you've done
whereas Alfred gives you a clipboard of
I think it's the most recent 100 you can
change the number as well ok so it gives
you a history of pretty much everything
it's in rich text format so it doesn't
strip the format's copies of formatting
through and all the rest of your image
is whatever and if you want to strip the
formatting you hold down shift and then
it does that yeah it's about as slick of
a workflow tool as you can get but it
across everything so whether you use
your website at your computer for
designing websites whether you're a
writer even if you just use if your
MacBook from doing articles of
university work whatever it might be
there's something in this that I think
will improve it is akin to speeding the
trackpad makes me so happy to hear that
because I recommended Alfred to Kris and
it's 20 quid or something yeah and
obviously there's a sense of her are
shaped like tell someone else to buy
this yeah if he doesn't get is value for
money out of it it's gonna be on my head
which is a single most painful 40 on it
well someone else has spent money at
your request and it's nothing it's not
being a value to them so yeah that's
Alfred definitely there's another part
of Alfred which is a game changer which
is the snippets so if like me I do a lot
of social media and a lot of the social
media posts that I write have elements
in them which are the same Alfred will
allow you the same as what's called text
replacement on iphone basically you can
write a short selection of characters
which will expand out into either a full
word a website and give us some examples
so for me I use a lot of the time I use
go get our guest list text space - space
and then a phone number now that phone
number is different for each event that
we use so for me to go back and have to
copy this out of my notes is really our
G was previously where it's now I've got
VV 1 through to a a 1/4 Aloha mmm one
for both the Manchester night I was
means that I don't need to go back in
it's just automatically pulled across
now what I've also got is much longer
replies and responses so I've got my
standard canned responses that you would
yeah so if I get if if someone asks
about they want to send some products
out or something like that then I've got
a canned response in there with line
breaks formatting my address my phone
my telephone all of the bits that that
people need and it's just done the the
Expediency is incredible
yeah it's pretty terrifying so have a
look Alfred I don't think you can
download a trial version you can get the
free version that it's not fully
functional okay but to be honest once
you've played with the free version
either like okay yeah it's 20 pounds
it's 20 15 years like so the function
the functions you've described there
even just the text expander and
clipboard manager worth 20 quid that's
it that's so there are dedicated
clipboard manager apps and dedicated
text expander apps that I've tried and
either mugs hold accountable to oh yeah
and Alfred is still better even like for
each of them individually even though
it's not a dedicated app for it so just
absolutely get it just by Alfred for
example yeah so as Chris said you can
start typing your phone number or your
address or whatever and it will expand I
have kind regards Yousef the problem is
sometimes I forget that I have it on so
I'll type kind to go into God's you know
and they'll jump on the back yeah right
so text replacement on iphone was
actually one of mine
so what this is is the exact same thing
is the text expander that we've spoken
about on Alfred but it's on your phone
so if you think it's specially on your
phone a lot of the time what are the
things that you need to type in so your
phone number your email address
addresses if you go this is on iPhone
I'm not sure what the equivalent would
be for Android settings
general
keyboard
placement and then if you go it's got
the entire automatics in my mind palace
here top right let's press the plus
button the phrase that you put in at the
top is what you wanted to say then the
shortcut is optional and that allows you
to expand it out so for me I've got EML
expands out to my email my num expands
out to my phone number and it means one
of the main things is you're never ever
going to get it wrong if you've got it
right that one time you're never gonna
type all your email address or your
phone number again because you've
outsourced getting it correct to a
previous point when you knew it was
correct exactly so unless you got it
wrong then yeah well you know just case
you're really [ __ ] and you've been
[ __ ] for a long time so you can also
have some fun with it like we did with
Ben where you change app or the earth or
in two I really like it when you put
your thumb in my bum to friend or
whatever just complete gibberish yeah
yeah right well we got next
okay so shall I just quickly run through
the potential features of Alfred just in
case you're listening and you on I think
I saw I think we've sold Alfred on this
one and we'll come back to advance
Alfred okay cuz you are right I didn't I
didn't expand on the will go advances
Alfred on another one fine I mean we as
I say I've got a one-hour webinar on our
that you can listen to so yeah get in
touch so next for me is to Bex now this
is one that you actually got me onto you
know I think we are the chosen for you
at this point
oh they're not allowed to download
anymore yeah god we you know what we can
leave I think concerned it yeah I don't
know so if you have the cooler on your
iPhone you can make sure you back it up
on your mark and that anyone on request
you can send them the file though it
work yeah so but it just means that they
can't get it from the App Store anymore
well she Rex was is such was a
alternative for YouTube which allowed
you to play youtube videos in the
background while you do other tasks on
your phone
so I finished doesn't allow which so
yeah it's crazy
I suppose it makes sense from YouTube
side but yeah it would allow you to use
youtubers audio only the same way as
Podcast that might do or whatever it
might be so I'm doing the amount of
audio on YouTube like the amount
lectures and stuff yeah they used to be
a way where you could open it in a
browser and then close the browser swipe
up from the bottom and press play and
that would work but that I don't think
that does anymore
right okay so I'm gonna have to check on
Chi backs and see if anyone's got an
alternative to it I'm gonna presume it
gets shut down because it's breaching
YouTube's Terms of Service include not
playing way exactly
it's YouTube's term not but if you have
a rooted I for a rooted android phone or
a jailbroken iPhone then you could do is
that even a thing anymore it is people
it's not becoming it's not as popular
because more and more features
optionality remember when you have to
download an app on your iphone to have a
flashlight or you'd like put the video
mode on and swipe did you ever have an
iPhone when that was the case yeah there
wasn't a native flashlight from the bots
from the dock at the bottom
come on about that crazy so ok next one
for me quid coat so this is a game we're
on financial terms today on where you
can tell its new tax year quid Co is a
cash back site online and I couldn't
believe that probably the most frugal
person who I know which is you didn't
know about it and then increasingly the
more people that I speak to they also
don't know about it so I may be thinking
it's not quite as so renowned as I set
up an account in I think 2009 2010 from
my flatmates advice and then just never
used it here and I've realized that
actually yet missed out on so much
potential probably close to a thousand
pounds over the last like five years
yeah so basically basically quid coat is
a site a cash back site you can go
through it to get to purchase pretty
much anything online my protein muscle
food BT sky a lot of utilities
FirstEnergy all that sort of stuff EDF
they're all on there jet2.com there's
pretty much everything from groceries to
utilities electronics consumables all
that sort of stuff and yeah you get
varying degrees of cashback amount now
the the big money is to be had when you
sign up to
but stuff it's a monthly direct debits
or things like switching your energy
over switching your what you're looking
at there 110 pounds if you switch the
first utilities yeah yeah like I'd
manage to batch together I think about
150 pounds to go over to Sky
Plus with like a new new member joining
thing and it meant that my first six
months with the sky was free of my next
four six months was 50% off like great
so yeah it was it's pretty it's pretty
impressive
well yeah it's it's the easiest thing
the world's I'm just gonna use alpha it
to create an a calendar event so that I
can remind myself to do that other
virgin broadband there you go well I
mean it's just if the optimization is
just through the rhythm isn't it so yeah
quit Cole quit cuz definitely one that
everyone should be using you you're
spending the money anyway so you may as
well trying to save it
are you still alfred in your draw me to
go again
okay I'm gonna go again cool um so I've
only recently started using this site
and I can't remember who introduced me
to I think I might've just found it
online but it's called medium and I've
got Johnny and Youssef onto it as well
medium is essentially a hosting site for
articles that kind of the same way that
reddit is a meta blog this would be a
meta and I guess a news article site so
you got a thing yeah if you type in on
Google if you want to find out about bio
hacking let's say and you type in bio
hacking for sleep Google will rank your
results based on relevance but not
actually based on quality whereas medium
is one platform which has a whole bunch
of articles hosted on there annoyingly
Google ranks it based on relevance to
you as well yeah so your previous search
terms which just means you get stuck in
this echo chamber and you don't actually
get to that's a big thing isn't it
there's a whole bunch of studies that
have been done where they'll have one
person will type in like war in Iraq and
or just just Iraq and then one person
will get a lot of war are because the
other person will get like want to
travel to Iraq oh really
yeah like based on what their history is
being cuz you get this curated newsfeed
so yeah medium instead of it being based
on relevance medium basis it on other
users ratings so there's kind of an OP
fo and a down vote the same way is
similar to the way that reddit works are
supposed and yet the the content that's
on there for me personally is fantastic
I haven't spent as much time on a site
in ages
it's a lovely partner app for iPhone it
remembers your reading place it will
deliver you similar articles to once the
eve of revolt it previously and that
you've that you've been what reading it
will give you an estimated read time at
the top as well which I absolutely love
yeah I said okay typography as well yeah
it's just really really clear very well
put together and some of the articles
that are on there a fantastic a lot
about optimization a lot of stuff to do
with news it's a bit Silicon Valley
issue I suppose any emerging platform
like this is going to be but there's
literally everything on there and I
think you as a more intellectual than
something like reddit as well oh yeah
it's it's quite serious to degree but I
found out the other day so I was reading
about what the scientific basis is for
why snapchat filters make girls look
more attractive
okay really really interesting very sick
clear skin blemishes so it achieves the
same objective as makeup does like that
does it's larger eyes convey honesty
youthfulness which is male the female
trait interestingly female to male males
need to have smaller eyes because its
maturity and its masculinity cheeks
blushed lips blush happens also on the
snapchat filters which is indicator of
readiness for sex and then it's like
talking about
what will happen apparently over time in
a society that values particular
characteristics is you get and I'm going
to butcher this I think it's recursive
fish Aryan
for cheryan progress of something like
that what happens is characteristics
which are attractive become exaggerated
over time to the point in which they
become caricatured so you've got to
imagine if you if everyone in the world
likes women who have big boobs naturally
through sexual selection women with big
boobs will procreate more which ends up
run it for five hundred years you've
just got these heads of taste with legs
right like walking around so you get
this almost like you overshoot on the
other side and it's playing off the
being a little bit ahead of the curve
it's really maximize the number of paper
clips your thing isn't there so and this
was this was all on medium just some guy
who wrote about marketing on on that so
what's up next for you very interesting
so mine is a Pyrex Bowl large Pyrex Bowl
cost me about one pound fifty back in
two thousand eight out of 10 years this
is the only thing you eat is the only
thing I have reached out of and it I
like I I invited my girlfriend round for
the first time to have a share a meal
with me and I realized like actually
we're both going after we are this pie
right so so we've got other plates and
things now but like that is just cuz so
easily cleanable it's indestructible
yeah
microwave it it's big enough to cook
large like bulk food in you can do cakes
and literally anything it could be a
mixing bowl so really if you're gonna
cuz it's our source or an article by a
guy who has 21 possessions okay and
that's it and I imagine if he'll have
like a spork and a Pyrex Bowl and I'll
be as his kitchenware and then they'll
have like a pair of boots and yeah so if
you want to go full minimal Pyrex bowls
couple I mean two Pyrex bowls would be
even better
yeah don't you twice as good so I mean
that just again the washing up time any
of these things there's no intricacy of
art it's just done yeah I like that a
lot that's cool right okay so up next
for me is some
thing that we've been I've done for
absolutely ages which is bypassing going
to the hairdresser's and getting my hair
cut either in the office or at home so
pretty much every single hairdresser
that you go to will also work privately
so all that you need to do go into a
salon move to a new city or you're in a
current location where you've been going
for a little while
speak to the stylist they usually deal
with that's committed to home visits
more tight like privately more times
than not they will do and then get them
round to your house or get them to your
office you don't have to leave where you
are yeah you need to clean up afterwards
that's a negative but on the plus side
it will be usually between fifty and
sixty percent of the cost an awful lot
less in humans yeah I would have thought
they charge you for a call art no no no
bloody hell okay and she did they just
do all the guys in the office
yeah so we we have one person who'll
come round and there's been periods
where she's done back-to-back like four
guys four of the guys in the office and
you just grin it back-to-back four guys
yeah she'll come round and that's it any
of their working aware on your phone you
don't need to leave work and on the same
as that is home visit car washes so
rather than having to drive to go to the
local hand car wash or the shell garage
to get your car machine washed you
shouldn't be getting a car machine
washed by the way and this is what the
guy who does our valine said because the
brushes break through the resin on the
top of the paint color fluffy carp so if
you actually look at your car the side
of your car if you've been getting it
done with the machine wash in the
sunshine you'll see that these are these
tiny little lines that bounce off the
sunlight and what that's due to is the
fact that these brushes are too harsh
and they actually chop away at the
resume and it's yeah it's nothing so if
you can if you're in the officer or if
you're at home
some people like the idea of washing
their car like that's cool I can see it
as a therapeutic activity the same ways
some people actually enjoy hoovering the
house but for me it's not so we've got a
guy who come out of house yeah we've got
a guy who comes around
and I think typically for a hand car
wash you'd be talking about maybe five
pounds or inside and out you like for a
mini violet you'd be talking about ten
so hook around and do I think inside
maybe seven and inside and out fifteen
but the quality is significantly higher
can you give me this guy's yeah you have
to let me know because there's a place
on walls end that does the best hand job
in town according to according to their
sign and you can see that they've
they've realized that mistake and
they've had to like rub away the word
job and see that the best hand and
everythin wash like on the side o land
what yeah but like it's faint you can
still see the faint job it's lying job
fake job they've really yes so yeah find
find someone who'll do home visits for
you for your car or your house for you
Carol your hair because it can I mail
I'm not thinking straight to take it all
I it's it's more efficient it's gonna
save you time on the haircut what 100%
save you money and on the car Vallot
maybe you're gonna be similar but you
definitely given get a better level of
service I mean what what do you value
your time at because driving to town
especially if your hairdressers is in
town you got drive to town got Park up
pay for parking mmm get out the car go
that you know mean like it's just and
the other thing as well is that you
don't have to take any time out with
your day to do this because most of the
times when under you fully sold on
that's not bad hairdressers are free
only reason I resisted is because I
thought it would cost more thought it'd
be like 30 quid just for to call out and
no no no no Louis you because you've got
a thing drying for guys when they're
working in someone's gonna pay overheads
yeah they pay whatever it is an
equivalent of a rental fee or sometimes
they have like a they have like a
minimum that they pay and then over X
number of customers per week or month or
whatever that's when they start to be
able to take their Commission's so they
can if you can carve the middleman which
is essentially the unit and the other
thing is as well like I always thought I
don't have to
hit at my house to get a haircut
properly thank bottle of spray water
which they'll bring clickers which
they'll bring put like do on hardwood
floor or pop mat down or something like
that bundle it up in your away just in
the garden in the garden you would go
over the course of a year you'd get a
very hairy garden though I see
especially you yeah the truth I shaved
my entire body from the neck down the
other day how did that go so I thought
it because I'm going away to a hot
country scene so I thought I better
better cool down when I run your arms
though uh yeah I mean arms like what
about legs yeah I've done legs did like
did legs but not arm yeah so okay but
I've realized it just makes you more
sweaty yeah I didn't realize the quicker
this way away right yeah so I think I
won't be doing that again
mmm so was it a lengthy task no didn't
take one to five minutes I bet you're
just a very rare Arab to be able to say
that yeah I mean uh luckily I've not got
a hairy back so my brother has so I
inherited all of the back hair yeah he
got all of the RMD he also got the
swirled gene which I find really
annoying yeah like it's lift yeah barely
yeah and I think it looks like he does
yeah very exciting so my life hat is
better touch tool we didn't discuss this
on the first one that we no no no so on
a Windows computer that this is this
feature is actually something that I've
seen so many Apple users just cheers
over because they thought that it was
never gonna come to mark which is on a
Windows computer you drag a window to
the left or to the right and it divides
the window or it snaps it to that side
yeah look this this has been around for
quite a while on on windows on windows
right yeah well I don't know how you
describe it but when you drag it to the
top of it it makes the window hafez it's
like a window a window optimizing
shaping - yeah right shapes it to one
side with the other side of whatever
better touch tool allows you to do that
it also gives you a lot more customized
ability over things like hot corners so
which corner you put the trackpad in the
on the Mac you can create key sequences
things so I've got one that's like if
I've got a tab open I can move it to
another space by holding down command
and pressing double tapping right or
left
okay there's also things for ya
maximising windows left and right with
keyboard shortcuts compressing all the
pictures in a PowerPoint so you've got a
PowerPoint open you want to make the
file size smaller so if you're a student
and you're downloading loads of
powerpoints and they're all like 10 15
megabytes each very soon that's going to
fill up your computer so better touch
tool will give you a way to set up a
workflow so that you can just it goes
through all the pictures compresses them
makes them smaller saves the file down
drops the file size of your PowerPoint
presentation
launching certain apps so like I
launched Evernote by like command shift
J it's a shortcut tool isn't it it's the
year it's the other side to Alfred as
opposed to a degree kind of yeah and and
you can make this app specific too and
if you have a new mark you can integrate
with your touch bar so you can
completely customize all the shortcuts
and touch bar and that kind of thing
okay I own it birds on it's time I'm not
trying to fit on trade so this is a girl
who I know also has the melatonin
gummies which is what I was going to
speak about now hello I can't remember
the name of the company they it'll be in
the description below so melatonin in
fact I'll put this looking to use the
Alfred search GS yummy that's it yummy
no so you can't get you cannot buy
melatonin on Amazon in the UK you can
buy products branded as melatonin but
actually its 5-htp or it's anything else
yeah you can't get it in the UK and if
you try to buy in the UK I'll say that
you can't see you've just got add to
wishlist there we'll see your buying
options so that's not it's a sounds in
America yeah well there you go and it
won't ship to the UK either so can you
briefly explain what melatonin is so
melatonin is the sleep neurotransmitter
it's just it's the metabolites of
serotonin serotonin metabolizers into it
which is just what's released naturally
when you go to sleep now you can
supplement with it which will promote
your natural production of melatonin and
help you to sleep better and in the
studies it looks like a melatonin
reduces your sleep requirement by about
an hour in summer according to some data
so it's nice to use as a way to reset
your sleep cycle if you've either been
traveling or you've had a late one you
need to kind of reset things a little
bit it's not something that I would take
every day but it's useful to have as a
backup a nuclear warhead so Matthew
Walker from why we sleep he talks about
melatonin use and says that his sole
advice for his primary advice for it
should I say is for resetting sleeping
patterns and that would be particularly
useful if you are sawn into shiftwork
someone who has varied working hours
like myself or someone who travels a lot
and is potentially moving through
different time zones so I use these
melatonin gummies I've got no idea
don't ask me how it's called yummy which
is the company that does them a link
will be in the show notes below I have
no idea how they return them in the UK
because as far as I'm aware melatonin
isn't available you can't even get
melatonin I don't think on prescription
it's just not available in the UK you
can get on prescription but you that's a
few things earlier or like severe
insomnia because I went and spoke to my
doctor about this I'm not sure even
doctors would prescribe it to someone
who's not autistic or have a child
developmental problem really I think as
an adult I don't know if they would give
you melatonin I think they'd probably
give you dr. Cohn or some kind of
sleeping pill okay but yeah which is
potentially is that a lesser list and
this taking less natural approach that's
natural and it's been implicated in all
cause mortality which is interesting so
all cause water so like you will you
will die of any cause you you are you're
more likely to die of any cause if you
take more than three sleeping pills a
year all right
that's terrifying so like whatever just
what stupid statistic well anyway so
yeah I've got no idea how this company's
retelling them but I am I spoke to them
I dropped them an email and I asked them
to explain why is that the Gummy's work
more effectively now I'll do am I'm
gonna be talking about sleeping in an
upcoming podcast so go through that a
little bit more detail then but yeah
melatonin for resetting sleeping
patterns especially if you're doing
shift work if you're traveling a lot
it's a real game-changer for me I
struggle to get to sleep there's a lot
of times I'll get in from work that's
6:00 in the morning and I look at my
clock and I think right I'm finishing
work now and in 24 hours I'm gonna want
to be getting up ma I need to go to
sleep wake up go to sleep and wake up in
the space of 24 hours in order to be
able to reset my sleeping pattern
appropriately and the only way that I
can do that is by using melatonin
because my circadian rhythm is just so
off yet itself thrown out and the
dangers of shift work people who do
shift work they die I think on average
10 to 15 percent sooner certain it's
pretty bad isn't it the high rates of
diabetes high rates of heart disease
high rates of cancer much higher rates
of Alzheimer's so yeah try and train
sleepers sacredly as you can and assist
yourself with melatonin it's a it's been
a real a real assistance for me so yeah
my sentence good of course him as well I
you can yeah I imported some yeah it's
legal to Odin everything but yeah it's
not controlled substance it's a strange
way in the UK that don't have it so I go
some brought over from Canada that I've
been using some sublingual ones the
dissolve under the tongue and then moved
on to the melatonin greens after that
yeah exactly
one of the problems is that because
they're kind of like just too sweet they
taste really good
so the tent that like temptation to
overshoot it's massive oh yeah it caused
myself into a coma with 20 grams of
melatonin warning velocity and the the
optimum dose of melatonin
one milligram yeah so there is like if
you have too little or too much it has
less of an effect than watching close
range
it is odd some some drugs work like that
and luckily I've got a I've got the loan
was endures as well and you can split
them into quarters
yep and their five milligram lozenges so
splitting them into one point to five
milligrams last fine yeah does the job
for me next next is my current
electricity supplier called the bulb no
I was with npower who and power if
you're listening you are terrible like I
looked them up on Trustpilot no point
four out of 10 rating oh my god
so what they're just they're just been
consistent surely they could just get
some of their mates to go on I'm gonna
text are like I think there's such an
overwhelming majority of people that are
just like zero is here but awesome so
that they're really awful and I switched
to bull I went on the thing and I was
like okay switch to bulb it's like hey
put in your address here's what your
quote will be and it it's consistently
the cheap person to tariff possible and
they only have one tariff and power how
about 150 tariffs based on what so weird
it's designed to operate it and confuse
you is that why it's very because it's
like Germany remains green everywhere as
well business is the cheapest and they
only have one it's just like flat low
gate and it's because they're they
everything that they do is from
renewable sources okay
another result they got a huge amount of
angel investors and government funding
for I could just highlight piling into
it yeah so basically that happened I
filled in the form which was like a page
it was like four fields to fill in and I
pressed okay and it was like there you
go
you've switched the bulb was like so I
called them up and I was like hi it's
right in fact right I gave him a call on
the number on the website and it just
went man hello this is George speaking
that's for calling bulb how can I help
you I wanna [ __ ] you
multiple option things for me too yeah I
straight through to here I'm a bit taken
aback it wasn't ready I was I was
prepared for the ten minutes of all
of selecting a circular options of yet
and I was like I've just filled in the
form is that it yeah like what so now
you and my energy supplier is like yeah
we like to make things easy right okay
looking home great so from doing that
I've got 50 quid yep I did a good koi no
you didn't quit didn't quit coach I
should have here but you can also if you
refer any friend yeah they get 50 quid
as well awesome so if you don't mind
Chris I'll switch your switches some
point oh well I was gonna say if you
don't mind me mentioning my my referral
kit I'll put it on the show links below
fine
Bob doctor at UK forward slash refer
forward slash Yusef why us EF but and
you get 50 we both get 50 quid that's
awesome it is great so I've made 250
quid from bulbing [ __ ] which is amazing
that's like it is it in bulb credit or
is it in real money it's in bulk credit
okay but three is real money even as bad
as it yeah and the app is excellent it's
all really simple like look at the cost
simple the interfaces on the website and
you can select those are the addresses
that I've got on bulb so yeah that's
cool
just switch but hang on did you have you
referred like your mum and yeah oh
nothing refer anyone yeah they don't
have to be I'm just trying to think
about how how far you yes my sister yeah
yeah yeah on a similar vein to that
booking.com ah
unbelieva I don't know I don't know who
else like hotels.com I suppose ornate
rooms are all right but booking calm for
me is by far and away the best place to
book hotels have used trivago I haven't
I don't either
if you know how to see the adverts for
it yeah I seen the adverts for as well
well booking.com is the best interface
large selection of hotels always got
good ratings from users so the same
reason that I like to use Amazon is
because there's a high amount of high
degree of user feedback on all of the
product and the same thing goes for
booking calm so there's an awful lot of
previous customers the
leave feedback about where you're going
to go and stay and this mediates the
search priority that you get so you get
one so that might be a three star but
like nine out of ten or one that's a
four star but five out of ten and the
four star will be ranked further down
and it does it does stuff based on them
the number of options nor the rest isn't
a star determined by objective measures
yeah yeah so the actual star is the I
can't mean it E is a number of bathrooms
over yeah that whatever criteria is that
hotels are gauged on but then there's a
user rating which isn't and you can sort
by users not like it's a nine out of ten
for a three star no although customers
will have used that in their review
because I'm three star presumably will
be cheated yeah not a bad that's not for
an Englishman you know isn't it that
kind of thing no I understand so yeah
booking calm and then if you pound it
enough I think it's if you spent about
five hundred pounds on it you get
something called a genius-level discount
which is ten percent off all valid stays
forever yeah
what so once you spend five hundred quid
on booking calm I think I don't know
what the I don't know what the criteria
is but basically when I was in Thailand
I was using working calm for everything
I'm part way through my part way through
my stay they said congratulations you've
now you're now eligible for genius
discount and basically there's some
hotels that do sign up to it and some
hotels which don't
but recently I've just booked my hotels
for LA where I'm going in a couple of
weeks and Best Western la is so
expensive Best Western for nine nights
should have been eighteen or like
seventeen sixty and I go it's like
fifteen thirty or something like that
Wow
okay great yeah it's it's awesome I've
used booking.com as well it's and you
can get stuck what reminds me of it was
the fact that you can get 15 cent I'm
sorry 15 pounds refer-a-friend
I heard funny we both get 15 pounds nice
it's just the sheer number of places
that are on there as you said and the
amount of data and yeah choice and rooms
and things yeah
very good yeah what's a nice
so I'm trying to ultimate between online
and offline avoidance because I feel
like so many - silly little apps yeah so
this is called ena iina okay
it is a wrapper a user interface wrapper
for a something called mplayer I think
which is a Mac Audio Mac multimedia
video audio player okay the reason I
like it is again keyboard shortcuts very
simple very lightweight it's like really
small file size opens instantly it saves
the place where you are at
so you open it if you're watching a long
lecture or something and those are the
window if you open it again in a month's
time it will just restore back to where
you were at before I know a lot of
people use VLC yeah that's what I've
done I've switched over from VLC to this
just because it's it's just so much
better you can change the speed and the
volume and everything and skip forward
and back five seconds or 30 seconds with
the arrow keys
it's all just so instant and it just
feels like you're just plug it into the
the media wrong it's weird isn't it
especially on a macbook that QuickTime
is just so [ __ ] clunky my voice and
it has it and they seem to have this
deal with QuickTime that they've had
felt like however many words long fight
is it okay remember when Windows used to
do realplayer
you know that was it prayin of [ __ ] but
yet media play classic if you're on
Windows is what you need that's the or
you can get VLC also but media player
classic is about as lightweight as you
can get and you can do stuff like you're
you're talking about there which is
where you you can actually overshoot the
audio volume so you can do like a preamp
so you can actually have volume audio
volume 150 percent obviously ill degrade
the quality but it'll make it louder
very quiet it's just sounds like sounds
like noise right let's get to more each
and we will finish up so I'm gonna do a
bit of a plug here not for anyone who's
affiliated with me but just something
that I love called and unity so and
junuh beats is above and beyond record
level they also have a podcast which is
called group therapy
and on June a deep and junior deep is
the deep label portion of that so if you
can imagine what for anyone I'm trying
to explain what like deep progressive
house music is to people who don't
understand it's slow melodic non drop e
trance for wonderful better term it's
very very ethereal gentle flowing meet
music it's it's simultaneously non
intrusive but also it's not just music
no bio you can have it one widely
working and it's not gonna like disrupt
without some crackers that's exactly
what it's here for
so and unity for working is what I use
so and unity podcast is 210 episodes
something like that now and most of them
is more than enough to I oh yeah they
looked and they released one every
single week and they're all awesome and
from start from the start intro which is
also very gentle gentle
after a minute there is pretty much
usually no vocals until the end except
for a few songs that tend to have that
in and vocal samples and for working it
just provides this lovely soundscape
that doesn't intrude on what you're
doing very serene very gentle nice and
melodic some of the guys in the office
like to work too so I'm more popular
music although more sort of could be
stuff hip-hop and stuff like that but
for me personally I found it really
distracting my my mind gets carried away
by the words that come in from the music
and for me I'm junuh deep it's just the
perfect sounds getting to work too so
search on whatever you podcast up is
have a look around unity you can give it
a crack when you're working it's also
another thing if you like me work in an
office that can be loud and you need to
not have distractions audible
distractions in order to focus one of
the advantages of this kind of music is
that because it moves across a number of
frequencies and there's a lot of synths
going on it doesn't actually have that
much dead space in and imagine if you
were listening to
hip-hop or drum and bass not your best
sorry the hip-hop or the music that trap
music I suppose where you'd have these
breaks and silences in the music that
you actually ends on hearing the sound
coming from other people to glaze us
over any of the exactly we've got if
you've got earphones and it's almost
like white noise but really really
lovely white night so apparently people
find random so it's silence but with
random noise unpredictable noise but
it's stressful
oh yeah because hand - yeah I'll say
like apparently humans find out as a
document yeah I've seen the study saying
that compared to right so it offline
rice cooker yeah if I don't want to know
I need to order the life hacks - to do
the ones that we've discussed already as
we start to do more and more of these
yeah rice cooker you can pick one up for
30 quid new 10 pounds on face book
marketplace which is another life hack
as one if it is a happy doesn't know it
causes me more like a service isn't it
it's definitely a fail 5 hat for the
Earth Day but yeah so rice cooker
it just makes perfect rice every time
like how easy is it to mess up it wait
this is not a rhetorical question it is
very easy to mess up rice in a pan I've
never iron is daren't Doran's don't wife
sister Hannah cannot cook rice like
can't really see I wanna cook right so I
shoot or forget it she can bake cakes
and you as well like you Arab yeah I
mean like slices rice is literally in
your blood well so I mean I've got I've
got the hang of it now
we're making rice on the pan but then
it's like it's just unnecessarily
difficult for compared to rice cooker
put the rice than the thing cover it
with a bit of water and press pawn and
then you just leave and then if you
let's say you go to the gym yeah like if
you cooking rice on the pan you wouldnt
be able to talk Jenna
whereas this you press on it detects how
much water is in the thing by weight and
then it stops cooking when it's the
perfect but when I said the optimal
avoid Athena's I like I like my rice
slightly well done can you can i edit
yeah you can't so depend this difference
there's eight settings on it and you can
like yo8 my different types of
brightness is what like if this is what
the Chinese use it's got to be if it's
good for a sedative right
it's definitely good enough for us right
on the topic of food muscle food member
muscle food yet very good yeah they are
so muscle food are a bulk meat supplier
they a uk-based company I'd be very
surprised they're up for me as
ubiquitous as my protein now but they
basically allow you to buy large volumes
of meat and other things as well now
like pre-packed vegetables like potatoes
and stuff like that a lot of sodium all
sorts not others and all sorts of stuff
but for me the main thing that I use it
for is for ordering chicken breasts the
bodybuilders grocery isn't it basically
yeah their meat is also really nice
quality it's not just like the [ __ ] in
the supermarket chicken breasts well
often you fry it and then it'll shrink
by half the size or something yeah all
of the meat there is what you see is
what you get it they do an excellent
pastrami thick thick sliced really tend
to like as if it's just been cured off
the well but it all cured me it's been
cured off the cow but it just is so
fresh and lovely quite expensive food so
yeah a little bit but there's enough
variety on there that you can have
different different options so for me
getting five kilos of chicken breasts I
think it's it's so cheap like it's it's
far far cheaper than going to Tesco it
arrives a house the only issue that
you've got is the fact that you're going
to get meat delivered in a package and
if you're not in at the time
it'll get left somewhere because they
won't take it away if they take it away
for parish so it's like it'll get left
at the front door you'll get left of
your
the store as I'm going to leave a
special place yeah and the problem is if
you are not there like if your
availability isn't tied in with the
delivery schedule
you're either left not being able to
order because you don't need to waste or
potentially risking wasting it isn't
ideal they put it in a cool bag don't
they though they do yes so it'll last
for I think lasts for about 48 hours in
that or they claim that it'll last for
48 hours it's not really good it's got a
lot cool like ice packs and stuff it
goes if you're not gonna be home over a
48-hour period then you shouldn't be
ordering large amounts of meat yeah so
yeah there is a there's a code that
muscle food are very kindly given me
that anyone who's listening can use um
for transparency I'm not making any
money off this it's just the same I use
the same deal that they gave me when I
need to what when I need to order
chicken but I'll pop that in the show
notes there as well
it's a em wisdom 10a check out and
you'll get some you get some free chick
and wisdom ten and wisdom ten gonna do
that now
so yeah one more okay one more
I bought a rope not a roll-on like a
bomb deodorant yeah the day so I wrote
on Amazon so previously I used to spray
deodorant I'm not a big fan of aerosols
or and I wouldn't use it
aerosol antiperspirant either cuz
there's a lot of other disrupt this is
think this is a big thing in America
right like yeah I mean I'm I'm not like
super paranoid about this it's like
magnesium content and stuff isn't it
yeah like I'm the only minion other
minions it yes a few other things that I
I just think like given the choice even
if it's not that bad like I realize it
because I think going full tinfoil hat
on this stuff like you're pissing in the
wind because there's so much
environmental exposure to see no
estrogens and that kind of thing that
you're not going to be able to show it
all out yeah but I feel like if I'm
going to be spraying something in like
lymphatic drainage points daily then
probably makes sense to go for something
that's not gonna be adding to it yeah
so it's I'll find it it's called mancave
eucalyptus deodorant barn thing okay to
stick I've only used it for a month so
far but it's barely touched the size in
terms of how much I've used yeah seven
pounds but I feel like it's gonna last
five or six months at least
really and it smells lovely so is it
it's quite effective I was gonna say is
it um like an all-natural yeah of what
what what's the difference between that
and what you spray on yourself so this
is it's alcohol free and it's made from
a bunch of like a plant plant bombs and
that kind of thing okay and it also just
smells really nice like that's that's
primarily the reason why I caught it
because I thought it was after you
mentioned in the previous life hacks
about burning eucalyptus oil and I was
that high we lovely to have some kind of
toiletry the thing about my letters you
said I had to look online I was like
okay that looks fine like if it wasn't
for the smell honestly I wouldn't have
bought a natural alternative any because
I don't care enough about it to but it
just kind of tilted the balance I
thought well it smells great and it's
good alternative yeah go for it that's
pretty cool I guess if you know him and
as far as like deodorizing what's the
effectiveness very good is it like I'd
say better than sprays released yeah
that's crazy I'm no expert on this stuff
but no right okay let me see I got time
for one more right so find the one that
I'm going to use is a tactic called
working from zero now I think I'm right
in saying that this is David Allen's
getting things done right I think that's
where it comes from
if not it's a Productivity tool which
allows you to try and clear as much
mental clutter as you can so you live
all seen someone's phone where you got
to type some me or make just put your
phone number in aro whatever and you
look and it's got like 45,000 unread
emails oh man
yeah you need my girlfriend has 13,000
unread what and it's on her home screen
all the time right is this red number
and it's like okay so how do you know
when you've got a new email do you reset
your baseline of zero to that 13150 to
like that's that okay it's worth thirty
thousand one hundred fifty three I must
have granny mark on that yeah so I'm
working from zero is an approach to
productivity which is that all
notifications and all and Red's are
taken out at all times and I think for
me it's a really really nice way to keep
my phone screen clear obviously I could
clear my phone screen by not having
notifications on but that defeats the
purpose of the usefulness of
notifications so yeah for me if I've got
an email that comes through I deal with
it as quickly as possible and if I can't
deal with it as quickly as possible
I'll read the email sorry I won't read
the email
clear off the read and then set a
reminder to go back to the email because
what you don't want to do so we discuss
the mail but alert in the last one
wakens you can do that it's news it for
example yeah so your inbox only has
things that are to be actioned yeah yeah
immediate it's just a nice way to work
and marking things as unread is a useful
tool but up to a point if you has like
very slow because yeah if you've got
stuff that's been on red for like three
four days that I just need to deal with
it like an it's there in the back of
your mind causing anxiety so he only
emails that I have in my inbox that
remain so the so open main box
it's either things that I haven't looked
at here and I need to go and process
which we're just done in batch every
week or the things that remain there it
would be like a flight itinerary for an
upcoming or like a train ticket or
something that needs to be in there even
with that you even though you could put
it and never take it out with that but
you never know clear off the note okay
so really there's no excuse to have
emails in your inbox
especially not 13,000 no but yeah that
just terrifies me
like they're the level of her of anxiety
that that would cause with Pete would be
frightened cuz people say are numb to it
but it's designed as we discussed in the
technology what technology doing to us
podcast with the hacker in your pocket
the the little red notification circle
is designed to it's read for a reasons
your alarm color and its design is on
your home screen to make you I always go
that's all time so there's gonna be this
background hum of stress from having
13,000 emails yeah it also makes you
feel like a waste month when you just
got yeah it's just an ugly looking home
screen isn't it
I saw the guys have got like fifty three
unread I messages my figure unread I
messages that's just like the most
priority of people that you've ignored
like cuz the thing is you can't even
mark them as unread you haven't even
opened them so with our message I guess
rather than like the ball ache of
opening a message I deal with it later
so reminder easier to just open it deal
with it so in my ties that ties in with
a two-minute rule which is from David
Allen's game things to any task takes
less than two minutes I think you can
extend that to probably like three
mm-hmm if any task takes less than three
minutes just do it do it now do it don't
meet idli don't shed you links it'll
take longer to share these edges go back
oh hang on right what's that especially
so this is the thing I was saying about
don't read the email just put the
reminder in because if you read the
email contextualize it then put the
reminder in they've already done half of
the work and you've got the background
noise I understand what it is yeah so
just a thing just get it done let that
get the work out of the way it's gonna
take three minutes so I think something
important to add to that is you said
managing your notifications making sure
that it's working from zero is also to
only have the permission for apps to
give you notifications that have some
materiality in your life yeah so don't
allow a notifications from an app that
you're never gonna be able to do
anything with don't allow it
notifications from like aster or
whatever it is because unless it's
something you need to do yeah it
shouldn't be interrupting your so like
for instance I've got notifications off
for headspace
I've got banners on
and they send like two or three mindful
moments are there which is nice it's
like what was you know I'll control the
see but you can learn to first wave yeah
like great that's nice that's a nice
little thing for me to see partway
through the day but it doesn't leave
anything is read on the home screen
even though head spaces on my home
screen I suppose in a way as well that's
it's kind of value-adding it's not 10%
off urgently the same lighting goes the
same thing goes for group chats here or
any notifications that aren't generated
by people directly aimed at you this is
going back over old ground on hacker in
your pocket podcast I'm creating this
stuff yeah but yeah like group chats you
can afford to knock the notifications
off because you will check your phone in
any case to be honest I'm pretty
menacing about just leaving group chats
as soon as anyone asked me to a boob job
move it it's like if someone wants to
talk to me they can send me a message
directly right are we done try another
one yeah
final one final one you pack okay this
is great
what's that so how often have someone
sent you a youtube link or whatever and
you click on it is like not available in
your country or like production so
replace the word tube with pack pay PA k
okay in the URL leave everything else
the same and it'll mirror it'll find the
mirror that works and no way yeah it's
amazing
that's all you need to do that's crazy
so it's like a VPN services yeah
someone's just made a cop a direct copy
of YouTube and it must feed in life hmm
just you pack and this all I think
there's also buttons added to the bottom
of life download video and although it's
just the most like spurious counterfeit
yeah I don't know how it's a lot but
it's all a fraud but if that's allowed
and achieve X is gone Oh ad for the
people that can't have G breaks in their
life I know I'm sorry guys it's a real
game changer I mean we could bring T
Beck's back one person at a time we
couldn't put it would be you know I
gotta go sauce my fifth yeah
I'm not sure anyway we will be back very
soon life fails 101 will be coming we
started it but we still need to finish
it I think you've got more life fails
than you do life happens so many both
we're gonna need to just sin bash
through the mall I think um who else
have you got coming up so I've got dr.
you a professor you and Lawrence who is
the writer of the author of the healthy
writer which is a book on the
workstation optimization I've also got
Leon Scott who is the main model for
Cheney naval and Hera London nice big
Instagram following you would think from
the outside looking at a professional
footballer as well you'd think pretty
much nothing between the ears but this
guy is mad into his mindfulness crazy
crazy deep in his mindfulness training
there's a lot of compassion stuff really
really interested speak tips I'm gonna
sit down with him obviously on videos
can look lovely as well of course I'm
excited about these especially healthy
writer yes I think I think you and
Lawrence is gonna be really interesting
guys just come off Ben Greenfield
podcast actually I had a binge of your
other episodes recently yeah Quinn henyk
was excellent if anyone's listening and
hasn't heard that yeah it clears up any
misconceptions about mobility
flexibility self myofascial release any
of the kind of self maintenance stuff
yeah also I would be keen because I know
people message you a lot more than they
message us really my but if you can let
us know about the life hacks what
problems you are trying to solve in your
life or what field because there's so
many of these that it would be good to
know generally what the kind of but the
likely it is if someone else has
encountered the problem that we've
probably got a solution for it as well
it's just that again can't see the wood
for the trees due to this manic
obsession with optimizing yeah and will
have bypassed it the same as Alfred it's
exactly not like because of our manic
obsession allottee with this stuff we've
probably come across it and done
something it's already been fixed yeah
yeah so drop me a message or give me a
TM and we'll go for that and
next time it's Johnny absent here
experienced here in spirit and in blob
but not here in real life came by done
[Music]
you